from uh the athletic and stadium is
champs charania back
on the rich eisen show from the bubble
how are you sir
rich i'm doing good how are you i'm
doing well so what happened
with the celtics and what is going on
let's start with the the past and then
the present what do you got for me
yeah so i i did some reporting this
morning on the athletic
and uh you know marcus smart was heard
yelling and shouting
post game by media members by everyone
around kind of the locker room scene
last night
but i'm told him and jaylen brown had a
heated confrontation they had to be
separated
um in the locker room by teammates
before it got physical
and marcus smart from what i'm told
stormed into the locker room and
essentially was telling players
and coaches that everyone else is is
is being absolved from blame while i'm
being
uh being the one that everyone's finger
pointing their finger toward
everyone else needs to be held
accountable as well other players need
to be held accountable
and as he continued as his voice kept
going uh
jaylen brown uh snapped back and and
basically told him that he needed to
cool off that
um he need to calm down and that the
players have to have to win and lose
games together and i think some of that
from what i'm told stem from smart
getting into it with a couple of the
coaches during the game
verbally and it was a tense interaction
uh there were objects um you know you
have different things in a locker room
and there were objects thrown around and
uh before
these guys could be uh physically
confronting each other they were
uh separated and uh you know from what
i'm told
jaylen brown is very fond of marcus
smart loves marcus smart as a teammate
so these things happen in locker rooms
this was definitely
something that multiple people involved
felt
was you know pretty um um
it got it got a little extreme but
uh these things happen they've smooth
tensions over
in the last 12 hours and uh you know i'm
gonna look to
to learn from it and move toward game
three a pivotal game three as they
as they trail too well now i'm not fully
aware of what the local media is saying
but
um or if this is a media driven uh thing
but
where is marcus smart getting that uh
he's the only one to blame
here what where where's that come from
that's coming from teammates that's
coming from coaches i mean that's
obviously got to be coming from
somewhere right
he's got he just played in the game so
he's not on his twitter
um you know there was a shot that marcus
smart took late in the game
a fade away jumper from the left
side of the floor that you know i guess
that could be a shot that you could look
at
that maybe teammates coaches had an
issue with
and as smart was making his way into the
post game locker room
he felt that he was being blamed for
that shot for that loss
and and he resp and he responded you
know marcus smart is the leader he's a
winner
the the celtics have been the playoffs
all six years of his career they've made
three
conference finals uh in the in his six
seasons with the team
so he he everyone around the team
understands how bad he wants to win and
sometimes
his emotions he makes it known and he
wanted
other guys other players uh whether it
you know whoever it may be
to be also be held accountable if people
are going to also put blame on him well
maybe we will look back at this and say
this is the turning point moment you
know
if should the celtics survive but the
heat man they look like the proverbial
hot team you don't want to face right
now
shams yeah no question jimmy butler is
playing at a high level on
both ends before last night his shot
clearly was not going but
he did everything else in in his power
to to will that miami team
bam adebayo had a big uh second half
and you know brad stevens is gonna have
to make some adjustments here
um with his lineup uh with his uh
defensive adjustments there's going to
be
changes that need to be made going into
game three and we'll see what that is
gordon hayward is continuing to make
progress to potentially return
um and those are the two things that the
celtics need to identify
this marcus smart jaylen brown incident
is not something that that's ideal that
these guys want but it's something that
happened
and uh they need to move forward but
miami
clearly has the edge right now and and
and uh you know as a 2-0 lead
go ahead and ask the questions of sham
that you got in my ear chris yeah
last night the heat went zone and it
just totally
discombobulated the celtics kind of the
same way toronto and nick nurse went
zone and kind of did the same thing like
why is that an issue for boston playing
against a zone like that
great question just not able to make out
shots when teams go
zone like the raptors did it to them and
now miami did them they're not
able to get the ball in the middle of
the floor and that might be a tactical
adjustment that brad stevens needs to
make
um going into game three you know
talking to people around
the team that is something that they
looked at that we need to figure out a
way
to to to to match up against this zone
and so
um that remains to be seen how will
brass even get a player
on the middle of the floor and get
outside shooting uh perhaps gordon
hayward's return could alleviate that as
well
what do you think do you think he comes
back do you think we see him
because they're down 0-2 and they're
just like let's go gordon let's go what
do you think
i i i don't know if it'll be game three
but gordon hayward is planning a return
at some point this series it could be
game four you know it's interesting rich
the
game three to game four uh game three is
going to be saturday tomorrow
game four is going to be wednesday so if
you want to use those extra days you can
but
um there is an expectation that he will
be back on the floor at some point
champs charani are here from the
athletic and stadium inside the bubble
right here
uh on the rich eisen show okay um let's
get to
um tonight's contest um the nuggets and
the lakers i mean lebron
said everything that he should have said
and perhaps truly believes that the
nuggets are
a force to be reckoned with how do you
think the match-up looks what
what is the conversation in the bubble
about this matchup between the nuggets
and lakers
shams listen denver's still going to be
regarded as an underdog and i think they
they understand that and and now it's
they're gonna have another series where
they're gonna they're gonna be
uh the underdogs and lakers are gonna be
the the favorites in this there's no
question
uh but the nuggets look like they have
it in him and everything
so far that we've seen in the playoffs
has has you know
they they find ways to win games they
find ways to compete jamal murray is
playing with such a swag
right now nikola jokic is looking like
probably the best player
or if not the one of the best players so
far in this playoff series uh in this
entire postseason
throughout the nba and so denver
definitely looks poised and uh i
wouldn't one adjustment i do expect the
lakers to make
you know coming off that houston season
i think they will play a lot bigger
expect more minutes
for dwight howard uh he did not play
much against the rockets
who guard is it rondo on um on murray is
that who we're going to see
who i could see i mean obviously they
start with lebron james at point guard
i could see kentavious caldwell pope
starting on jamal murray but
you know you have rondo coming off the
bench alex caruso
i'm sure will also get a lot of clutch
minutes
on him as he did in the houston series
on james harden or russell westbrook i i
guess
what i mean is crunch time like if
there's a crunch time moment
third quarter he's catches fire like we
saw him do against the clippers
who is the guy that when it comes down
to it is going to is going to mark
murray is it lebron
you really think so i it would not
surprise me if lebron james and crunch
time takes
uh effort on jamal murray that'd be
great but you know the the primary
defenders i would probably see okay
davis caldwell pope
alex caruso uh in in some form of rondo
potentially but
you know in terms of clutch moments i
would expect caruso lebron
kcp okay that'd be great shams here on
the rich eisen show
let's talk clippers um what's the
aftermath is doc rivers
in any sort of trouble with the clips
i i haven't heard that i i think that
you know there's a reason kawhi leonard
paul george wanted to come to clippers
docker
was a major reason uh this loss was
difficult
there's no question about it and now
they're gonna need to find a way
to and a lot of it might come internally
they're gonna have
you know a couple parts that they could
look to move i think uh getting another
playmaker
will likely be a uh priority for them
this summer another guy a point guard
and a back court potentially
but they have the talent they have the
pieces they just did not perform at the
level that they needed to
and and you know paul george didn't step
up to the plate in clutch moments
the one off game kawhi leonard had so
happened to come at the same time that
other guys
were also struggling the williams
couldn't find
a a you know his stride in the playoffs
mantra's herald so
they could easily run it back they have
the talent they still have all the
pieces to compete
for a championship birth did paul i mean
is there really any truth
to paul george saying like was did the
did the clippers really have an approach
this season prior to the pandemic and
then post
bubbling up in the bubble that this year
wasn't the year anyway
that they had that they had more runway
than this season to win
championship or busted they was that
really the mindset of the clippers
because that
i found very hard to believe shams
technically they did have the runway
they have next year with paul george and
kawhi leonard under con
under contract before their prayer
option years but overall
this year was still looked at you know
from all players
coaches the championship was the
ultimate goal this year anything short
of that
and that's the expectation that the
clippers put on themselves when they
went out
got kawhi leonard and bh he traded
multiple draft picks shea alexander
uh goes alexander for paul george that's
the expectation you put on yourself with
the championship coach and doc rivers
the talent that they have on this roster
this is a championship
level team uh lawrence frank docker
these guys have high expectations
nothing short of a championship would
have satisfied this clipper season and
i'm sure you weren't surprised by it
um but maybe the ferocity of it uh nba
twitter and the rest of the nba
from magic johnson uh to
cj mccollum and damian lillard uh just i
guess three people jumped at me
the wide spread glee with which the rest
of nba twitter and nba players
took uh with the clippers blowing it
walk me through all of that those who
might need a refresher
were you surprised with the ferocity of
everybody just having so much fun
at the clippers expense no i really i
mean i saw a couple blurbs about it i
saw a couple tweets but i
didn't really get to it obviously i was
at the game and did post game stuff
so i didn't really fully get into it but
listen i mean the clippers they put
these
the exploitation the pressure on
themselves and now
um you know you're gonna have to deal
with it these are just things that you
have to deal with it's noise and uh
i would expect them to to be right back
in the thick of it next year well i mean
just to give you a
you know cj mccollum was pointing out
that they you know
essentially that the clippers voted to
not be in the bubble anymore but he
didn't think that they would go out like
that
he also tweeted out uh he was wondering
if they packed their
bags before the game damien lillard
inviting them to cabo
um you know magic johnson saying that
they choked again
i mean is there such an animus towards
the clippers
league wide champs i i i
wouldn't say animus i think that they
you know they they
there were commercials done there were
billboards made in la
um you know proclaiming their dominance
um
you know if you talk to lakers fans i'm
sure they would say you gotta go win a
ring before you glow
and so uh maybe maybe they did get a
little
you know a little ahead in terms of the
marketing but again that's that's all
stuff these players can't control
and what's done between the lines and
done between the line denver
you know for them to come back from
double-digit deficits in those last
three games and win
i mean you know credit to them last one
for you
um sham sharonia hear from the bubble
when do we hear from giannis
who's expecting who uh you know we're
expecting to hear him being the mvp
um when do we hear from giannis about up
up or down on the concept of
of a um of a super max yes or no i know
we saw him tweet out saying i'll see you
next year
bucks fans but uh when do we actually
get rubber meeting the road on the most
important item
with him yeah yeah we don't even know
when free agency is going to be
you know it could be anywhere from late
november december
and so until you you find out more
clarity for next year i i
don't think giannis has given it that
much thought
he's on vacation on greece and he will
spend the time with family and
and kind of distance himself from the
season
and everything like that um uh you know
right now i don't think right now he
doesn't have to give a yay or nay i
think that's probably coming closer to
november
december as free agency dates are set as
next year's cap
is set as there's more future about next
season so
give me the team he's on next season
crystal baldwin for me as we're sitting
here in the middle of september
what do you think i i would expect him
to stay with
milwaukee next season okay because he's
under contract all right shams thanks
very much we appreciate you taking the
time man
thanks guys i appreciate it you got that
champ cerrano here from the rich transit
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here